[Music]
there's a rumor a showbusiness rumor
that I keep hearing and I can't believe
it cuz you do a terrific job on the show
but there's a rumor that Simon Cowell is
going to fire you why is that rumor out
there and what's it all about okay
it was a joke he somebody had written a
book on him in England and it had said
all the girls women that he had sex with
it was a book that discussed the women
that he's been with specially yes and so
you know the English tabloids so it was
you know front cover of every newspaper
day after day so anyway somebody asked
me what I felt what did I think of it
and I said it he's suffering from small
penis syndrome small penis syndrome that
means that guys who kiss and tell
usually do that because they've got a
smooth and what they do is I know what a
small penis
let her tell
stories and anyway guys that do have
small Willie's whatever you want to call
it usually do say oh I've had her I've
had her because it makes up for the size
of the Willie Rick if you like men who
drive like have midlife crisis and will
drive like a red car a sports crew
that's true do you think if you see a
man driving like a red expensive sports
car it means he's got a small penis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh good lord you shouldn't really enjoy
yourself on on America's Got Talent
it seems like a fun job you get to see
all these you know acts that are so
strange so unusual what's your favorite
one would you say so far that you've
seen well this season definitely my
favorite act is a dog act it's this
father and son and they have all these
kind of different types of dogs they're
all mops
by the way they rescue them and they're
just incredible and they've trained them
to do this like incredible snow
different things than I do I believe you
brought some clips and what are these
dogs in action let's take a look it's
fun
[Applause]
[Music]
really who would you love to be on that
show where you don't have to sit there
and look at one singer after another I
mean that's a show that's my question is
how do they get a dog to do that the
first time do you know what I mean but I
know I went backstage to see because
we're not allowed to talk to the
contestants so I was just going to hover
so I'm hovering to see if they were nice
to the dogs and they were really nice
the people that you know do the dog act
they love them and it was just just a
delight and they didn't even sing how
fabulous so you're saying you don't like
singing shows I do I'm just bored with
them yes yes I see what you're doing and
it's ingenious it's ingenious let's talk
about something very happy we'll have a
big wheelie
[Applause]
why are you asking about we need to
Danny teller
oh my god it's a monster
right now God is growing angry